-Our first guest tonight
is an Oscar-winning actress,
a best-selling author,
and the founder and CEO
of Goop.
Goop's latest product,
the G.Tox Reset kit,
is available now.
Here is Gwyneth Paltrow,
everybody!
Ohh, my gosh! Yeah! Come on!
I'm so happy to see you.
Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah.
I'm so happy to see you, bud.
Thanks so much
for coming on the show.
-I'm so happy to be here in this
weird, surreal, virtual way.
-Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
What is even going down?
How is the family?
How is Moses and Apple doing?
-Oh, they're so good.
Thank you for asking.
Yeah, they're nearly 18 and 16.
Moses is about to get
his driver's license.
-That is insane to me.
-It's all happening.
-It's all happening, bud.
-How are your girls?
-They're so cute. 8 and 7.
And just awesome
and just so fun and creative.
And I love it.
It's just the best thing ever.
I ran into Moses over the
summer, by the way, with Chris.
And he's --
Not only is he a stud,
but he's one of the nicest kids
I ever met.
So great job with that guy.
-Thank you.
-And give my best to Apple, too.
I never bring her up enough.
I don't want her to be like,
"Does Jimmy not like me?"
Because I love that kid.
I've known you
for so many years,
and I remember
when you started Goop.
And it was --
I was like, "Oh, I get it.
Goop. GP.
Gwyneth Paltrow. Goop."
And it was, like -- I think
it started in your kitchen,
I want to say,
and you were sending out --
It was just newsletters?
-Yeah.
-And now you're the founder
and CEO of this giant company.
I mean, what is the best part
of running Goop?
-Oh, my gosh.
I think the best part --
and I know it sounds,
like, counterintuitive --
but the best part
is how challenging it is,
because I learn so much
all the time.
And I think,
if you start in one career
and you kind of have the
gumption to kind of jump ship
and do something else,
not only are you sort of
working against, like,
what people think
you're capable of,
but what you think
you're capable of.
And so you just
are in this position
where you're learning
all the time.
And it's just -- It's scary, but
it's also incredibly fulfilling.
And I feel really alive,
and I really love
the people I work with.
We have such a great team
at Goop,
and that's probably
the best part, is the people.
-Yeah, everyone loves
working for you and with you,
by the way.
Everyone I've talked to --
They love it.
What are the offices like?
Are you in the office now?
Or are you in a cloud somewhere?
Are you --
-We're in a cloud.
We were so excited to all
go back and be together
and get back to our
kombucha on tap and whatever.
-Yeah.
-But we're all back in our
closets/offices -- home offices.
-Zooming.
-And hoping that, you know,
at some point this quarter,
we'll be able to go back
and be together,
but I guess
it remains to be seen.
-I went to a Goop store.
You have stores.
-Thank you. We have a couple.
-I know. I didn't know this.
I was like, "Wait. Goop store?"
So I went in --
I went in with Nancy.
And I will say this --
It was in Sag Harbor.
There were the nicest people
working there.
They were so nice.
And I was like --
And it was so curated
and clean and beautiful,
and every little thing is cool.
And I was like, "Oh.
This is just so well done."
And you do this stuff,
and you go,
"Okay, this is, like,
good for you."
And then you do edgy stuff.
But then you do stuff that
has, again, helps everyone
and has a great purpose.
You've teamed up with the ACLU
with a new candle.
You're not making any money
off this.
The money goes to ACLU,
all the profits.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I want to show --
I want to show the candle.
And I don't know. I just --
Maybe I think it's better if you
tell everyone what it's called.
-Yes, the candle is in honor
of the anniversary
of "Roe v. Wade."
We made a candle called
"Hands Off My Vagina."
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-They love it.
[ Laughs ]
But you know what? It's edgy.
But that's exactly --
It gets people talking,
and it gets people, you know,
to donate to a great cause.
-You know, I think we are very
pro-woman at Goop, obviously,
and we really do believe
that women should have agency
to make whatever choice
they want to make in their lives
in any area,
and so we were happy to be able
to partner with the ACLU
and do this.
It's really exciting.
-How do you come up
with new products?
Do you just write them all down?
Do you record them on your phone
in the middle of the night?
Do you go like,
"Oh, this could be an idea
or this could be something"?
-I usually get them sort of
in a lightning flash,
like I did with this candle.
I was having a dinner one night,
and we were talking about
freedoms in this country.
And it just sort of hit me.
I was like, "Oh, I would love
to make a candle like that."
And sometimes they come from
collaboration with the team,
and our team can come up
with, like, the funniest,
cleverest names for products.
-Yeah.
-So it's really --
It's a great process, you know,
to be able to have that
creative freedom at work
and to do things
you know will be edgy
and, like, move culture forward
and get people talking
for a good cause.
So we love it.
-Now you've branched out
to even, like, TV now.
You're doing TV shows.
You're doing podcasts.
It's become the biggest --
It's become giant,
as big as you like, really.
Do people come to up you and,
like, ask you for advice now?
Like, "what can I do?
How can I start my business?"
-Yeah, they do,
and I love that, too,
because I, obviously,
learned on the job.
And I didn't even
finish college,
and I didn't go to
business school or anything.
So I've made so many mistakes,
and it's probably taken me a lot
longer to build my business
than it would somebody who had
done it a million times before
or had, like,
incredible experience.
And so I really want to save
other entrepreneurs that I know
from making the same mistakes
that I made along the way.
So I actually speak to a number
of entrepreneurs weekly,
and I invest in companies
and help however I can,
you know,
if I believe in a product.
Because I really do think
that the entrepreneurial spirit
is such an important part
of being an American
and the freedom to invent.
And so I love being able to get
that chance to help where I can.
-Yeah. I want to talk
about your new detox kit,
called G.Tox, when we come back.
-Oh, yeah.
-More with Gwyneth Paltrow,
everybody.
Stick around. Come on back.